everyone talks about needing a 14-day  warranty to minimize you know to protect  each other has there been any talk about  everyone who's gonna go film on a movie  going somewhere for 14 days and like  sort of isolating and then I mean that's  a you know we hadn't talked about that  it's you know that that that could only  work in a circumstance where everyone  was at the same hotel and you weren't  interacting with the outside world and  then you're asking people not to go to  dinner or get a drink  you know so it would be hard to control  on that level what I think it's going to  come down to and you'll you see what  other countries are doing really  effectively as they using testing and  they're using quick testing and they're  using frequent testing and they're using  information and tracking the virus so  that so we know where it is I think that  not until testing is ubiquitous well you  see a return to normal life